Female Voiceover: The
false mirror presents us
with this enormous, lashless eye.
Its iris is very and implausibly filled
with this luminous cloud-swept blue sky,
and then right at dead
center is this matte black,
opaque disk that doubles as its pupil.
Male Voiceover: Before cleaning,
the pupil was very shiny
and glossy and refelctive.
Once the vanish was removed,
the black became very soft and deep,
so it really does become
the focus of the painting,
and you could also see more
details in the clouds in the sky,
also details like the highlights
in the corner of the eye
became much more apparent and visceral.
The white that forms the highlight
on the white of the eye is in zinc,
so it's a cooler white than the
lead white used in the clouds,
which are softer and warmer.
We can actually distinguish these
in x-rays images that
we have of the painting.